[Musique]
et bien je suis une
enfant de la balle qui était joueuse de
tennis yvelinesoise mais au Chesnay et
ma passion c'est le sport et les enfants
et plus largement les humains la
relation humaine
[Musique]
c'est une association
qui existe depuis 16 ans maintenant
à l'initiative d'un joueur de NBA tous
les ans pendant le Tibet je faisais des
dons à une association de sportive de
haut niveau et borisio m'a prise par
surprise puisqu'en 2006 devant l'UNESCO
devant toutes les fédérations et les
champions il a décidé que nous allions
créer notre propre association et que
les sportifs de haut niveau seraient
derrière cette association au profit des
enfants
alors si break est né parce que j'ai
démarré ma carrière chez Nike France il
y avait la chance d'être directrice
communication et marketing passionné de
tennis j'ai joué à Roland-Garros
et je rencontrais des sportifs de haut
niveau de sport comme le tennis le
football etc qui gagnait très bien leur
vie mais à côté de ça j'avais en
partenariat des champions d'athlétisme
de triathlon de boxe qui était déjà
extraordinaires qui avaient une histoire
à raconter et qui gagnait pas bien leur
vie et je me suis dit il faudra trouver
une occasion sur terrain neutre de
rassembler des champions des
personnalités sportives de toutes
discipline et quoi mieux que
Roland-Garros puisque moi j'étais
passionnée j'étais directement par le
directeur de Roland-Garros et je lui
donnais cette idée je lui dis un grand
tournoi il y a des joueurs qui se
mettent au vert pendant la semaine de
calife le golf c'est un espace
magnifique pour se concentrer pour
l'agilité etc
si nous organisions un événement sur
terrain neutre avec les joueurs de
Roland-Garros et des champions
le directeur de Roland-Garros a tout de
suite validé mon guide en me demandant
de d'organiser l'événement à cautionner
depuis 32 ans voilà il m'a permis
d'utiliser la belle Roland Garros et de
m'ouvrir les portes de Roland-Garros on
a accueilli les champions et l'histoire
de Steve break est née en 1992
les champions pour être champion je
pense que derrière les souris etc la
bonne humeur il y a beaucoup de
disciplines et il y a des il y a des
fractures on devient pas champion par
hasard il y a des milliers des dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui ont CDI ce
qui arrive je pense que
c'est une histoire particulière c'est
des fractures d'enfance etc et quand ils
réussissent qui sont au sommet qui sont
réussis dans leur sport ils n'ont qu'une
envie c'est de transmettre et ils le
disent tous on a envie de rendre ce que
la vie nous a offert et parfois en une
journée une phrase un sourire un regard
ça va transformer la vie d'un petit
jeune qui va tout un coup avoir un
objectif va rêver et quoi de mieux que
de rêver et réaliser ses rêves face à
ses champions
vous avez beaucoup de demandes comment
vous choisissez les jeunes qui vont
pouvoir rencontrer et échanger justement
avec ces champions
jeunes qui souhaiterait
rencontrer ces champions alors nous
avons des professeurs nous avons des
encadrants sportives des médecins du
sport des nutritionnistes et des
champions qui sont toute l'année au
contact professionnel allemand d'école
de collège de clubs sportifs et ce sont
eux qui sélectionnent des jeunes qui
méritent de par leur pugnacité de par
leur volonté de s'en sortir également
parce que ils n'ont pas obligatoirement
une vie favorable et que si on leur
donne nous un petit coup de pouce qu'on
est en soutien derrière et bah peut-être
qu'on va donner l'étincelle qui va faire
que ils vont saluer ils vont voilà
réaliser leurs rêves
Simon me demande toujours comment tu
arrives à avoir des lots aussi
magnifiques que le maillot de camavinga
de la Ligue des Champions celui de
Benzema offert par Didier Deschamps la
raquette de Federer moi je baigne dans
le milieu du sport et en fait toute
l'année avec SOS gazelles je suis en
contact avec ses champions je suis une
passionnée de tous les sports je suis
une passionnée de l'esprit de l'éthique
qui règne et du coup je les côtoie je
fais du coaching mental aussi donc je
donne un coup de main au quotidien et
ben quand on donne on reçoit et pour me
remercier ces champions qui savent que
cette cause est très importante nous
offre des maillots collector qui ont
marqué l'histoire du sport
[Musique]
l'administration fiscale selon des
critères très précis qu'il faut
respecter
nous permet d'être connu comme
association d'intérêt général pour ça il
faut qu'il y a un critère d'humanité que
ce qui concerne un cercle large d'enfant
et que ça soit désintéressé donc du coup
nous on a beaucoup de dons privés on est
un peu atypique SOS gazelle parce qu'on
fonctionne avec des amis des des
individus ou des entreprises amis qui
fidèlement parce qu'ils viennent sur le
terrain nous donne des nous font des
dons et pour les individuels qui
voudraient venir effectivement il y a
cette intérêt du CERFA qui permet de
défiscaliser
[Musique]
alors pour durer 30 ans je pense que je
suis bretonne j'ai 4 grands-parents
bretons il faut beaucoup de
de plus de nacité et moi j'ai une
philosophie c'est que je garde le
sourire et je ne montre que le meilleur
je vais pas raconter tous les offres
c'est pas facile c'est même compliqué il
y a des moments de désespoir de l'arme
des moments où on est déçu mais je me
dois pour ces enfants de continuer et
systématiquement dès que je suis avec
mes amis champions ou avec ces jeunes
leur sourire leur enthousiasme etc ce
côté spontané que moi j'ai peut-être
trop en tant que femme adulte
la machine repart automatiquement donc
il faut garder son cap et il faut
essayer d'être voilà d'être réglo avec
les gens qui nous aident et puis aussi
dire que la vie c'est aussi de la joie
de la bonne humeur il faut passer outre
toutes ces difficultés se dire voilà on
se fait des moments très justement pour
ces jeunes on oublie tout et l'espace
d'une journée d'une semaine etc on se
mobilise pour ses enfants et tous les
gens patristes tu viens enfin tous les
gens qui viennent sortent de là énergisé
avec un sourire juste enfin
extraordinaire quoi
[Musique]
alors il va se passer qu'on va
accueillir une centaine de jeunes de
collèges aussi bien des Yvelines de
Achères de Sarcelles qui vont
tourner autour de 8 ateliers encadrés
par des champions
box tennis rugby foot volley judo basket
yoga et tout ce qui est respiration
prévention santé et puis l'atelier
nutrition avec nos grands chefs parce
que c'est très important la façon de
s'alimenter et en parallèle les
champions les personnalités vont faire
une compétition amicale de golf par
équipe avec ce fameux titre de champion
des champions sur un très beau parcours
avec un trou en un récompensé par
audibower donc et beaucoup de bonne
humeur et tous ces champions une fois la
compète de golf fini viennent vers les
enfants et c'est la fête avant les
enchères caritatives
oui Yannick Noah c'est extraordinaire
c'est c'est un homme qui est à la fois
il a une sagesse et cet enthousiasme de
vie aussi et puis on festif il est à la
fois heureux de se dire 40 ans de
victoire 1983
dommage qu'un français n'est pas pris le
lead et c'était assez amusant parce
qu'on s'est retrouvé au Sénégal et huit
jours après on se retrouvait en Bretagne
sur un tournoi de tennis où le soir il a
fait un super concert avec cette
ambiance comme les Bretons savent le
faire et c'est un nez Roland-Garros va
être aux couleurs de Yannick Noah et ça
et sa victoire des 40 ans son coach
aussi Patrice agelawaer sera là puisque
c'est lui qui a marqué cette histoire
Véronique Chaplin quels sont vos projets
alors j'ai un petit scoop pour vous je
donc on fait beaucoup de choses en
France au Sénégal on a fait au Népal au
Maroc mais on a décidé depuis deux ans
suite au covid de se recentrer en France
pour diverses raisons
et j'ai des amis partenaires qui sont
venus en Bretagne voir les Estivales
quand des jeunes passent un stage d'une
semaine et qu'ils ont l'occasion de
découvrir la mer on a installé une salle
en attendant un centre qu'on va
installer en Bretagne
près de près de Saint-Malo sport
éducation santé un centre on accueillera
les jeunes qui seront parrainés par des
grands champions des grands noms du
sport et notamment des joueurs de foot
de Rennes et donc tout au long de
l'année il y aura des journées des
semaines
autour de ce thème sport éducation santé
avec des encadrants et tout pour que ces
jeunes soient heureux épanouis et puis
voilà face à la mer dans un cadre
idyllique
[Musique]